only seven percent of its juniors are
proficient in history one percent in
geometry and even less in algebra when
folks outside the watts area in los
angeles hear about locke high school
it's usually bad news the state ranks
schools from one to ten with ten being
the highest locke has a state rank of
one vicki reyes has two daughters who
attend locke after dropping in on class
she learned why the school scores so low
class was just like a zoo the kids were
running around they just do whatever
they want to do in the classroom and the
teacher was just sitting there reading a
book most of the times if we weren't
teaching ourselves we weren't learning
at all
locke has long been at the bottom in
academics and at the top for violence
there were sets of gangs who ran the
campus when frank wells became principal
of locke he says gangbangers did all
kinds of things to students
ranging from robbing them at gunpoint to
knife point to beating them up wells was
determined to turn lock around
step one was calming the violence if you
got into it dr wellsworth would take
care of you when it first happens he
would nip it at the bud before it grew
into a larger
problem but when wells continued to push
reform he ran into what he calls a brick
wall i began to require teachers to
bring lesson plans
to school every week
because i wanted to see their lesson
the teachers union filed a grievance
against me
trying to stop me from requiring
teachers to come to school prepared to
teach kids
at this school board meeting utla the
local teachers union was protesting a
payroll blunder in which teachers were
paid incorrect amounts for several pay
periods the lock controversy was also on
their minds what frank wanted to do was
get rid of all the teachers that
disagreed with him matt taylor is the
union rep for the area that includes
lock high
what is a bad teacher a teacher who
doesn't go along with a status quo those
teachers who refused to perform who
refused to come to school prepare for
our kids
i had concerns with the major problem
with locke was frank wells in order to
even get a teacher
to be seriously considered for
contamination you have to have three
years of perfect
documentation
on their insufficiencies
and that's just the beginning of the
process it can take possibly a hundred
plus years to fire all the bad teachers
turns out it takes much less time to get
rid of some principles
we were calling for frank's removal for
for a couple years in may the los
angeles unified school district
stripped frank wells of his duties the
district send three police officers and
an associate superintendent of schools
to
the school site to escort me off campus
and demand my keys now how could that
happen
well says that it was payback for his
support of a bold plan that would have
yanked control of lock high school away
from the district and the teachers union
the plan was inspired by this guy steve
barr i had a dinner with frank wells
we hit it off green dot had a history
of success in its schools with like
population green dot is a non-profit
organization headed by barr it runs 10
charter schools in some of la's poorest
areas
we go into areas
you know very simply that have sixty
seventy percent dropout rates and we
reverse that achievement gap we retain
and graduate eighty ninety percent of
the kids that come in charter schools
are public schools run by private
companies or non-profits like green dot
teachers have more control over how they
teach students and principals have more
control over things like who gets hired
decisions are made at the school site
not by administrators at district
headquarters
you've got thirty thousand people who
work at l unified for example that don't
work at school sites they're not
teachers they're not support people for
teachers
barr's office overlooks district
headquarters but he's not interested in
paying for a skyscraper or lots of
administrators instead he pays teachers
more
i want all the money at the school site
in the classrooms paying the best
teachers giving them the best tools at
green dot students are held to high
standards and schools are kept small to
give kids personalized attention the
idea is to borrow what works in the most
expensive private schools you would
never spend 25 grand to send your kid to
a private school
that's five thousand seats or four
thousand seats it'd probably be three or
four or five hundred there were the
number of key things that appealed to me
about the green dot approach there were
safety nets after school tutoring
saturday school and things of that sort
vicki reyes thought the green dot
approach could help turn lock around why
not try it when something's not working
in your life and you know you're trying
to do something a certain way you always
stop and say well let me start over and
do it you know let's try another
approach 11th grader nyla koich attends
green dot's oscar de la hoya school
she transferred from a traditional
public school but still keeps in touch
with friends there if i tell them
something like oh i'm learning about
this about that like oh how could you
get that it's like really hard and i'm
like well not really just like is how
the teachers explain it and everything
nila says there were lots of gangs in
her old school but not here
there's no gangs here it's really hard
for us to have a gang if anybody wanted
one and i don't think anybody would want
one because everybody's like
everybody knows each other well
at first nyla didn't want to transfer
schools but now she's glad her mom
convinced her to give green dot a shot
it's it's really sad that these parents
have been
manipulated by a
snake oil salesman like steve barr but
steve barr has plenty of critics
who
feeds at the troft of public education
and is nothing
but a
vampire for instance uni leaders see his
charter schools as a threat to the
traditional public school system private
schools and charter schools can cream
from the top they can also get rid of
any child that they want to public
school can't we never kick kids out of
school
actually public schools can opportunity
transfer and kick kids out of school
our mission is we never do that his
model disrespects teachers i'll give up
on a on a teacher faster than a 14 year
old kid they lose a lot of their rights
as
as teachers we don't build the schools
for the teachers that's the big
disconnect you saw in the board meeting
you know the president of the teachers
you just walk up and take over a
microphone take this anymore we have a
set of four demands that must be met
bizarre
you know parent would do that they would
they would take them out like in about
you know five words these demands are
immutable ucla have a lot to lose
because they will lose membership
membership means you lose money you lose
money you lose influence but plenty of
lock teachers don't side with the union
many joined with wells and pushed for a
first of its kind reform they wanted
lock to break free from the district and
transform into a cluster of small green
dot schools to do that they would need a
majority of lock teachers to sign on to
the plan within three or four hours the
teachers went and
after school got the majority of the
teachers to sign this thing and lock
high school was in play
that's when the district struck back and
turned principal wells into former
principal wells
vicki reyes couldn't believe it it was
terrible and it had an impact on the
children which made the children kind of
like go into a frenzy they just went
crazy the um school had a riot the next
day this is somebody that finally cares
about them when they was taking dr wells
off the campus i i started crying
because i felt like what is this school
going to be without him for the rest of
the year wells was ordered to report to
a district office that gave me a cubicle
next to the restrooms
at 600 a day to sit and do it nothing
the post petition fallout continued
the school district
and the teachers union called mandatory
meetings one after another
over the next week with misinformation
campaigns if you ask too many questions
at a green dot school you're just not
hired back for the next year frankly if
i was sitting in the room i would i
would rescind my signature after hearing
some of these things seventeen teachers
did rescind their signatures but
eventually steve barr convinced them to
sign back on with the majority of lock
teachers on board with the conversion
greenclad green dot supporters and
red-clad union supporters packed the
school board meeting
would lock break away from the district
i am appalled at a board
a new board that is willing to just say
give the children away the final
decision was up to the newly elected
school board
i'm supporting this charter today
which seemed just as divided as the
audience
because i'm not sure
what tomorrow looks like but i've had
enough of yesterday the teachers union
president argued that green dot
supporters didn't follow the right
process
this is a bad precedent for a public
body to set
thank you
steve barr watched anxiously so did
frank wells vicki reyes brought her
daughters and niece to the meeting to
speak out in support of green dot
teachers parents
board members
president superintendent everybody help
our students
after hours of debate the vote finally
came would lock be set free
you